my friends you may have seen the press
conference with joe biden
it was particularly boring he called
mostly on
favorable press he didn't ask a single
uh he didn't ask a single conservative
you know to speak
at this at this press conference and he
had your very obvious guess at one point
someone asked him a question about how
to solve problems and he's like
you know we gotta do we gotta work on
it's very
in uh okay
whatever and it was just basically shot
for shot that's that's exactly how i
remember it just stopped yeah
and i was like shut down like the dude
just stopped talking
dead and then like his brain just just
misfired and what's funny is all of
these journalists started saying
like they were defending him so i put
out these very um
powerful and profound tweets where i was
like joe biden's strength is exactly
what we need he is the champion we
elected
i'm like the dude literally just stopped
talking because his brain
didn't work and there are actually
journalists defending him but you know
who isn't defending him
kamahara snopes oh what'd they say here
we go we didn't get them
i got them they got them yeah from
snopes fact check now hold on there's a
lot of people who might not understand
the context of why it's funny that
snopes is fact checking this it's
because
like snopes fact checks the stupidest
way possible
there will be a story right like let's
say you know jeremy one day you know
you're the host of the quartering and uh
you you do cultural commentary so
there's a lot of lefties they don't like
you
let's say one day you ran into a burning
building and saved a box of puppies
and with totally great risk to yourself
and then everyone starts congratulating
you
as they snopes is the kind of outlet
that would say did jeremy hambly
actually run into a burning building to
save puppies
where the puppies actually racist no
they'll say
did jeremy hambly actually run into a
house to save
a box of small puppies while wearing
nikes
and then they'll say false and then
it'll say while it's true he did run in
the
burning building to save the puppies he
wasn't in fact wearing those shoes
that way what they do is the headline
has the big false next to it
they add something to the story that
makes the whole story false even though
it's 99 percent true
snopes does that yeah absolutely there
was one reason i came here what it was
it was like did oh yeah i remember did
ocasio-cortez exaggerate
her you know her fear from the capital
false
while she wasn't in the building when
the storming happened and she was in a
different building at a different time
she did say like it's like they they
just
they just play that game right check us
out did biden say
i came into the u.s senate 120
years ago oh they're going to say no
1901.
i believe it i believe it are you
telling me that's not true well so
well no no snope says it's true the
remark in question came during his first
news conference of the new
administration
rating true joe biden said with regard
to the filibuster
i believe we should go back to the
position of the filibuster that existed
just when i came to the united states
senate 120 years ago
you know what you know what i love about
this though look at this this is what uh
what they say
it's true that biden said these words
however it
was unclear if he misspoke or was simply
making a joke
you see how they defend this guy how
they
oh look at this we have we have this
tweet here zach
spoke zack smith on twitter who just
seems to be a regular guy noticed this
trend and lydia notices as well yeah
he tweeted i like how twitter is saying
that biden was joking
about him saying he's been in the senate
for 120 years bet biden smiles when he
jokes
he said that with a stern face he really
thinks he's been in the senate for 120
years
and twitter is trying to tell you he was
joking look at this united states trends
it says senate 120 in his bid to bring
back the former filibuster format
president biden jokingly said we should
go back to a position
of the filibuster that existed just when
i came into the senate 120 years ago it
wasn't a joke
there was no joke like a joke would be
like if he was like
he would have said something like oh
geez you know back when i came in we
didn't even have the filibuster because
that was what 200 years ago
yeah i'm kidding i'm kidding but you
know what i mean come on man it's a joke
you know
he was joking how was he joking well
like it was like i've been in the senate
for a long time ha ha
but 120 years is a specific number like
a really he would have been like a bad
joke
like you know we could go back to the
way the filibuster was when i went in
you know 100 plus years ago and they
would have been like ha ha you know was
that that fell flat
isn't it possible hear me out that joe
biden may be
a vampire he may actually be
a hundred and what would that make him a
hundred and forty yeah
he could if he was a vampire he could he
could theoretically be 500
you know yeah right but that would that
would imply that he got bitten when he
was in his 70s
that's unfortunate because you know when
you turn into a vampire you stay the
same age that's a bummer i was thinking
yesterday if you eat meat and you think
you're not a vampire that you're
you're good you're not drinking blood
dude you don't like grab the pig and
drink its blood
blood in that meat you don't look look
you don't
i tweeted i tweeted when i saw this i
was like all across the country
lizard people conspiracy theorists onto
their screen and we're like i knew it
the first thing i thought q is going
crazy
yeah all right lizard vampire confirmed
i'm tuning in to alex tomorrow i know
it's
i know yeah but he's not gonna actually
say joe biden's an immortal lizard
person you know what i mean highlander
how could you know that is he trolling
us has biden been trolling us this whole
time
he's gonna charlie and the chocolate
factories
[Laughter]
he walks forward in the press conference
and falls down and then spring because
we already think he falls we're afraid
that he's gonna get hurt
what if what if he's uh that was a joke
i was making during the campaign
that joe biden was only pretending to be
incapable of being
doing his job so that you know like
throughout the debates he's fumbling and
stumbling and struggling to walk and
slipping
and then finally when it comes to you
know to the final debate with trump
he staggers out falls down but then
springs up like willy wonka
and stuns the whole world and that gives
him the news cycle
so he wins the only problem is he's won
and he's still doing it
yeah so that theory is out the way it's
the long play man did you see they were
already asking him if he's gonna rerun
he's been the president for like a month
i'm like
are you gonna re-run he's like well of
course he said come on man
if you run again will you take kamala
harris like he's been the president for
like a month and a half
and they're already like yeah no but
here's the funny thing who can we
replace you with
the the funny thing about this press
conference when i think it was
i don't remember who asked him if he was
going to run again he said it was
his expectation how was it even a
consideration
every president like going back decades
has run for a second time like 100 plus
years or whatever
they've always tried to get i since fdr
i guess that's when we we got the
two-term limit
but they've always said i'll run for
re-election listen he's always believer
in fate
he's a big believer in fate right but
like he's willing it to be
what i'm saying is think about how weird
it is we're at a point
where we're arguing about whether or not
he will run when every other president
did you know what i mean in fact the
fact that biden is actually in this
position where it's questionable whether
he will is scary to us
the dude was talking and then just
stopped
and then went uh but whatever
dude he's haggard he's he's like he lost
he just like just lost it and now
they're like are you gonna run for
president again
you you know what the journalists are
actually asking them are you okay are
you gonna pass the torch
no they're saying are you okay like the
dude just gaffed in ridiculous ways and
they were like
are you gonna run for office again they
asked him in that same conference
yeah yeah multiple ways too
because i know it was funny yeah it was
really insulting and i loved it
but the they had um you know all the
i don't think i've seen a president on a
podium with more notes
no i'm not i'm not that he had notes
first of all i i don't know what's on
them
but every reporter that came up in my
opinion my guess is it was the reporter
their you know their political
background exactly what question they're
going to ask and the answer
because i agree who's next no no okay so
and so and then put it down so
we already know that reporters were
complaining jen sackey who's the
the press uh um secretary that's that's
right press secretary yeah that's
correct she had
requested questions in advance so when
biden's like looking through his folder
and he goes oh we got here um
janet and then he's looking down she
asks the question
and then he goes one second and then he
like folds the paper and goes
we got a fight and like he's got the
answers written down
oh my god yeah it was bad it was very
obvious and you know what was reading it
off
and whatever was on that paper i think
when he just was talking someone asked
him a question
he tried i think that's when he tried
you know what i mean
like here he is he's got all the answers
in front of him and they're going just
stick to the prompter
stick to the prompt it reminds me of uh
uh iron man remember that at the end of
the movie
when they're like just stick to the
cards and then he like stops and goes
down
i am iron man like joe biden tried to do
that
he doesn't have like the wherewithal to
actually say words without a card in
front of him or a teleprompter
so he's like they're like just stick to
the cards and he goes come on man
i read uh a thing
he had a couple of those really awkward
meltdowns i don't i know there's more in
the press conference we want to talk
about but the one that really stuck out
to me was the one that ended it
he was he was talking and then he just
like shut down and he's like all right
that's it
and then just like left the stage yep i
was like
somebody it was like somebody got in his
ear like all right joe time to go to bed
yeah sun's getting low now
[Laughter]
the black widow walks in yeah so it's
getting real low joe
oh so uh no it was it was actually kind
of funny when he ended it
he just like he's not he's not with it
man he was like
all right but now i'm gonna go thanks
and then just turns and just walked away
yeah it was like he pooped his pants he
didn't know what else to say
so he's like i gotta get out of here
yeah and he just ran off the stage
shouldn't that happen with nadler
yeah oh yeah he like waddled away or
something and people were like what just
happened to that dude
yeah i don't know if that's a true story
but it's pretty obviously a load all
right let's
let's let's talk about political bias
real quick because we have this tweet
that lydia pulled up from jennifer rubin
oh yeah
and do you know who she is she's a
washington post columnist and she's
supposedly a conservative
but she only ever praises democrats and
i'm like oh there's one of those on
every network though and there's one you
know right right but she so she tweets
the story opinion biden excels at his
first news conference
the media embarrass themselves i love it
the media embarrass themselves first of
all i've been saying that for four years
first of all so finally thanks for
joining the club but come on listen
i got no problem criticizing trump trump
if he deserves to be true
if if he deserves to be criticized when
he was president the problem was people
like ruben and the and the media
apparatus and these corporate powerful
interests
where like you know trump walks out on
stage in waves and they're like trump
literally just did a nazi salute
it's like yes he's just he's waving to
the crowd dude chill out that didn't
happen
now you have joe biden and i said it was
it was boring
it wasn't the apocalypse but he did have
these gaffes we expected them
and now they're like no it was the best
conference ever and
it's the media's fault these people have
their noses
so far up joe biden's ass they're coming
out his mouth well twitter had uh
top trending was like did joe and then i
was like oh what's this like i was
thinking that was
like did joe really say that but no it
was all like
did joe just conduct the most
professional press conference ever and
not
insult any journalists and say anything
misogynistic
and i was like look okay yes he stood up
there and he said some things
but and and to be fair they did ask him
about the uh they hit the unaccompanied
un accompanied minors thing
a couple of times my favorite joe
joe gaffe was him saying well
i never said for them to come here i've
never said that i've been saying now is
not a great time to come to america
but i'm not gonna leave him starve on
the border like trump did
nah he lied of course he lied nothing's
changed the truth is nothing's changed
yeah the numbers are the same
so i pulled up cnn of all sources and
cnn
was like it is true the peak was during
trump and we're nowhere near those
levels
and it showed something really
interesting the moment joe biden assumed
office
the number of unaccompanied minors
skyrockets from its lowest point in 10
years
to its highest point in the past 40 well
to its second highest point in the past
ten years a journalist actually said
that to him though she said
i interviewed a nine-year-old whose
mother told me
that she sent him unaccompanied and he
walked all the way from honduras by
himself
because mama told him that papa joe
would not turn him away
and then joe was like and joe basically
said like
well i'm not gonna let him starve so
essentially he was confirming
the message that he's not going to send
them away
but earlier in the press conference he
said oh we've sent the vast he said
vast majority of them back that's
something that
he said we sent the vast majority of
these people back which was otter
baloney
since he came in he he rescinded a bunch
of trump's rules
the remaining uh the migrant protection
protocols they called it remain in
mexico policy yeah i'm pretty sure he
ended that
which is now resulting in people getting
hotel rooms so like the blind
administration spent 100 million or
86 million dollars yeah putting putting
illegal immigrants in hotel rooms
listen man i love humans i want these
people to live rich full lives
what biden is doing is not going to
accomplish that it's going to serve the
interests of major corporations and
multinational industries
that want cheap surf labor from people
who don't have
rights in this country don't have access
to like
health care don't have minimum wage
protections and then what happens is
these companies exploit this labor
none of us like that we want people who
are in this country legally and properly
to have access to these jobs to work
hard and succeed and that includes
immigrants who come in the right way it
includes asylum seekers
but what they've done with the
democratic party with people like joe
biden
is they've made it either you let them
in wandering through the desert
sent off to who knows where or you're
racist
like you're a bigot you hate people it's
like no dude listen
they come to the border they say here's
my case we can only let in certain
amounts of people because
we don't have an infinite like we don't
have replicators like in star trek or
anything
but they don't they don't want you to
understand that resources are finite you
have a lot of these people
on the left claiming scarcity ended a
long time ago
it's just not true we don't want carbon
emissions to rise
so we don't want more people coming into
this country right no they don't agree
with that either it's like you're the
ones who say
we produce too much carbon now you want
to bring in a bunch of people to produce
like america produces more than any of
these other countries not china
well for sure but i'm just pointing out
the paradox oh right you know what i
mean
oh you mean like where they're coming
from they're saying that like we've got
all these problems you realize bringing
all of these people in is going to
result in a surf class it's going to
result in
it's an underclass they're not going to
be better served they're going to be
wandering through the desert it's a
disaster
what does it did did you hear how biden
said he would solve it
he said well what we're going to do is
we're going to put in street lights
see what you got to do is you got to
solve why they're leaving and so
one nation wanted street lights and we
put in street lights and crime plummeted
and you know what's crazy i heard that
when they do blue street lights
crime goes way down and when they do
halogen like the orange one
crime actually goes up why i buy that
because there's a thing with like how
you color you paint your walls and stuff
like yeah i don't know
i don't know i was just reading
something about it because like you know
you know like when you're walking
through a city and the lights are kind
of orange
they switch them to one switch to like
blue and white lights like colder
you know tones wow and then crime
dropped interesting yeah should just be
a law then
they should all be that color okay right
they should strobe they should flash
they should flash all colors of the ring
just go text everything yeah do it do it
everywhere and that'll
that'll deal with it yeah hey so before
we move on i just wanted to say about
the jennifer rubin thing
the byline on her article says reporters
have shown why these events are an
utter waste of the president's time you
see what they're doing here
right you completely get it she wants to
be done
with these pressers because they're so
utterly stopped holding my president
to any standard exactly stop it donald
trump
we threw him in the garbage chute joe
biden don't you dare talk
about it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you